oran speaking and learning and
optimization dynamic and avoid words
right so thank you for inviting me
I did not have to come from very far so
it's particularly pleasant to give a
talk in Berkeley so this is some joint
work with two students and Gary Chang
with another graduate student and Kabir
who was undergraduate of Berkeley and
it's not doing a PhD the theatres but
what do you think also how would gen
which somewhere here I think we started
working on these problems together we
were motivated by hospital scheduling
and we noticed that in surgery
departments the scheduling is very
inefficient so there are many periods of
time when the surgery team is idle
because some are just surgery finished
early and you are waiting for the next
patient that so that has not been
planned correctly and we know are so in
hospitals that many delays at the end of
the day everything is delayed and people
end up waiting for hours for the
exception so there's something to be
done there and we worked with a doctor
at Children's Hospital in Oakland and he
gave us data and also access to the
actual people managing the team so work
with some other colleagues here so
okay [ __ ] all right something is not
working
[Music]
so the problem is can be described very
simply you have customers who make
appointments with the service provider
so for example you make an appointment
with the plumber to come to your house
or with a dead test or repairment
awesome surgical team the features of
the problem is that the service times
are random it's not like talks here that
are well metered by booth service times
are very random and that's the cause of
the problem so you could space out the
appointments to he'd use the waiting
time actually space them out enough that
that will be good so you reduce the
delays of customers but unique reach the
ideal time of the service provider and
the overtime so that's not a good
solution so the promise to find a good
trade-off and this is the classical
problem so one way to formulate that is
to say well it's a multi objective right
we have delays we have waiting time so
and we have overtime
so let's minimize the expected value of
a linear combination so we'll find a
packet to envelope of okay so if I take
a look okay the old approach to do upon
no scheduling was to tell the patient
well come to the hospital the night
before surgery and you would be sure
that the surgeon would not have to wait
for the patient but of course the
patient would have to wait for the
search
well the plumber will come to your house
between 8:00 and noon right so you would
wait starting at 8 o clock in the
morning and he would show up at 2:00 in
the afternoon right so that so the new
approach tends to be dynamic so that you
tell the patient that we will call him
two hours before he should be at the
hospital so you get the text or you get
a phone call or the planner will call
you one hour before it gets to your
house so you have time to drive from
your office to home to meet the
theoretical questions okay if you want
to optimize static assumptions our
partners say that given the
distributions of the service times we
have n service times we want to find the
appointment times that will minimize the
expected cost
expected cost being this linear
dynamic appointments a little bit
default say well given the distribution
of the service times and the required
advanced warning times not T 2 TN they
may depend on the under customer find an
adaptive policy to notify customers when
they should come to the hospital or when
they should go on to meet the plumber
right you want to minimize the expected
cost in fact is that there is no nice
analytical property of the optimal
solution this is the static opponent
problems of well known problem and
people have tried to prove conjectures
about maybe the the concavity of the
time between appointments some other
properties but it turns out that you
find kata examples to all the
conjectures it's very difficult
numerically it's very hard so if you
could think well let's use dynamic
programming but if you think about it a
little bit you realize that it's
intractable because the state of the
system at any given time in the case of
dynamic assumptions it's when you get
warnings to the people before right so
we imagine you have that vector of
warning times that becomes part of the
state it becomes very difficult to deal
with okay pragmatic considerations also
are that you don't know the
distributions so even if you knew them
the problem would be hard but you don't
know them so what you in fact know is
that you observe samples of the surface
times so you can tell that this
particular surgery we have done won a
lot of those surgeries in the last two
months we have observed samples the
distributions change over time
so for example the server gets better
more tools new tools become available so
if you look at hip surgery replacement
right hip replacement surgery two years
ago by a given surgeon and you look at
it now well it takes much less time the
tools are improved the surgeon is
improved it's substantial
so suitable girls would be for us to
have a model free approach and that is
adaptive so that's what you tried to do
okay a bad approach that is used
commonly
if former certainty equivalents approach
so what you do is you you look at the
expected duration of the service so the
hip replacement surgeries you know the
average is four hours and then you
schedule for four hours then you are the
schedule for those durations well it's a
mixed integer linear program it's not
difficult to write down and sorry
why is it bad well it's because the cost
based on min durations is not the main
cost obviously because if you know that
if you assume that the durations are
fixed to their mean then there is no
waiting time there is no idle time
everything is perfect there is no cost
clearly that that does not help too much
you have to deal with the variability
okay so what will we do we do first the
static case to explain the problem and
explain the traditional approach which
is the TDR programming formulation and
then how we do it then I will talk about
the real-time scheduling which is I
think a new formulation of the problem
and a new solution okay so what is the
problem so imagine that you have five
customers that you have to serve and
those are the service times not random
what you do is you decide appointment
time so maybe the start of the day would
be the first appointment then there is
an ad of working day so we try to finish
everything before the working in the end
of the working day and you choose those
appointment times to number three so I
assume for now that the order is fixed
we have decided ahead of time the order
so this is what happens okay the first
appointment you finish here
well you finish early the second
shows up you finish a bit late right
then the third one well the third one to
pay the customer arrives here but you
starts to ring him when you have
finished the second one so on the news
like that so you see there's some idle
time and there are some delays so this
is the delay of that is faced by the
third customer that delayed it is faced
by a false one delay that is faced by a
fifth one and also there is some
overtime thus what you try to try to
minimize the linear combination of the
idle the delays and the overtime by
choosing the appointment times the
difficulty again is that the way thing
is this random so the idle time is idle
time prior to the last case the idle
time after the last case does not matter
obviously okay so an example you have to
- just to to anchor the model in your
mind right you have two cases the
durations would say iid and let's not
worry about the work time so I should
use schedule the appointment time the
second customer well see if you if the
first service finishes before the
appointment time you have a delay or you
have an idle time so you have a cost
which is the idle time which is the
appointment time of to minus D the
duration T 1 if T 1 happens to add after
the appointment time you have another
cost which is a delay so the delay will
be the T 1 minus a 2 what simple
assume that our fives 1 so what you see
is that the cost is just the absolute
value of the difference between 821 so
how do you minimize that well we know we
should take the median value of T 1 that
should be minimizing the mean absolute
value right and the constant will then
be the mean absolute deviation of this
random variable
it also says that if you have to choose
the order should I do two before one or
one before - if you have two different
distributions you should place the one
first that has the smallest mean
absolute deviation not the smallest
variance with the smallest mean absolute
deviation so the traditional approach is
this linear programming alright so you
can write down the dynamic it is very
simple the ad time of the first service
is e1 which is p1 the start time of the
second one is the maximum of jet time
and the appointment time and the same
for the other system so then you can
once you have from those times you can
fund the idle times of course and the
waiting time so for example idle time of
2 if the start time of 2 minus the end
of the first one so the cost is this
linear combination so say we want to
minimize the cost over the appointment
times subject to the constraints now
people notice oh this is a nonlinear
system radius max but if so the trick is
simply to say well we will replace this
max by saying the test two should be
bigger than those two terms so now the
constraints are linear the objective
function is linear it's a simple linear
programming home so now things are
stochastic so what people have done is
they say okay we have we'll do a sum
over the probabilities of the different
values so again everything is linear in
fact it should be relatively easy the
problem of course is the size very
quickly the problem blows up because if
you have M possible values for n default
durations and to the end quickly becomes
unmanageable so even if you if you solve
this and many people have to resolve
this you do not track the changes in the
distribution very well so your solution
that was good for the last three years
may not be very good now
because in fact you have not captured
those strengths so what do we do we do a
gradient I'll go in like everybody does
right learning has become either linear
regression or gradient I'll go ahead so
we do again I'm going so how does it
work well so let's look at this this
example so do you record unit cost idle
time is one delays alpha over time its
beta so what you do is that you look at
one particular realization just
stochastic gradient one particular
realizations of those times and you see
what would happen if I were to increase
my appointment I made 2 by Epsilon
what would happen well I would increase
this idle time but I would decrease this
one so locally the function derivative
is 0 right so the algorithm will not
move a two-degree never going to move it
which may not be a good idea because
intuitively know that they too should be
what closer to this time you do it for a
3-way what happens if I increased a tree
a little bit I will increase the aerial
time so the derivative is 1 so I will go
in the opposite direction of a radio
tower to decrease my cross so a tree
will decrease and time to be closer to
the add time of the second one it will
not move so we add up with this
disagreeing right where it will changes
it to does not know it's starting but
you can twist the along a little bit and
the idea is to add a multiple of the sum
of the start times so you add a multiple
of the start start time of the second
procedure on the second service in the
third one and by doing that suddenly yo
hago Edna will not be stacked so by
increasing the instant you will increase
one idle time right so you will end up
with a positive gradient so it will take
to bring everything down
so simple variation okay so the key idea
then is stochastic agenda said this
little calculations that we did by
looking at the gradient on one
particular realization is a form of
perturbation analysis you just trace the
effect on one particular simulation of a
little change
not by here doing the simulation but
just by tracking what would happen if
you were to change it so that we used to
be cut into finished a simple
perturbation analysis so for example if
you change it to a little bit you can
taste the cost very simply so the
algorithm will find very quickly the
gradient and then you will do the
gradient circusy gradient classic of
stochastic agent and what happens when
you do this well you get a very
efficient algorithm that uses only the
data there is no model there is a model
for the dynamics but no model for the
data it's efficient because you you hit
the gradient without doing any effort
right it's systematic and you can show
that the problem is luckily convex and
uniformly Lipschitz in the appointment
times so you know that it will it will
converge to the optimal solution why is
efficiency important because why not
solve big linear programs but you want
to explore many scenarios so for example
you want to change the default ordering
of this of the services and you in
practice you have not won a political
when you have many operating rooms and
you can dispatch patients to the free
operating room when you do this
unfortunately you lose Quebec City so so
this shows that it works right I don't
need to convince you of complexity by
doing simulations okay now the real-time
scheduling
it's a classical polling queuing theory
if you think of launch equations it's a
maximum of sums so everything's all the
ad times will be convex right and now
you look at so the ideal times become
convex the over time is the duration of
the day you look at the total processing
time it depends on the ideal times and
therefore it becomes convex or so
luckily it's the real-time scheduling so
if you think about a concrete situation
right you are doing surgeries in one
operating room the first surgery happens
to take only one hour instead of six
maybe you have to close the patient the
problem is too serious you cannot
operate or whatever right then do you
have done your static appointments or
the subsequent case is assuming a long
typical duration if you do not react to
the fact that the first case was much
shorter than planned
you can you will waste a lot of time so
you have to react in real time so this
is the idea of real-time scheduling okay
so for example say that the first
service you see there one hour or five
hours with equal probability how do you
choose a second appointment time well we
would typically choose the average right
or the medium if it's uniform right
so in that case half of the time you
will have a cost of two because you are
I don't right and the other are from the
time you will have a cost of two we can
see here of the delay now what can you
what else can we do well they say that
you need a warning time of one hour for
the second customer so what should you
do well if the first procedure adds two
after one hour you want the patient the
next patient says you should come there
will be a delay of course you will have
to wait for the patient for one hour if
the first procedure is very long what
should you do well you should not warn
him at time one
you know by time one that the first
procedure is not finished you don't know
when it will fill it but you know well
it's likely to finish at five so you
will warn him at time four so that he
beat with a right it will arrive exactly
on time so this is a trivial example but
it shows that a good policy that will
save a lot of time
it's a stopping time based on what you
have seen so far right now this is a
particular policy it's a particular
parameter a policy that says after some
time if the first procedure is not
finished I will warn the patient the
second patient right if it finishes I
should run in then so it's a particle is
not necessarily the optimum adaptive
policy but it's a simple permit really
so if a similar story so the idea is
that you warn the patient and patient to
at the minimum of the end of the first
procedure and some time X X becomes a
parameter in your policy and then you
will try to optimize over hacks that
will be optimized of regs will use a
gradient are going right so this is an
example of what happens a function of
the cost alpha of the waiting time if
you use a real time policy you optimize
over X this is the optimum value of x
this is the optimum cost if you do a
static appointment these are the costs
that you find the optimum static
appointment the optimum cost so you can
save quite a bit by being reactive not
surprisingly right
so if fairly clear that real-time policy
will be better than a static policy what
is less clear is how to parameterize the
policy so that you can find the optimum
within this class of this is another
example right so the key idea is that if
one procedure is delayed fills the
appointment time of the third one
depends on the start time of the second
one when the second one slides
automatically the third one the
appointment I will slide as well
so you will avoid a cascade of delays
that we see in typical static
appointments so the formulation again is
that one particular customer number
three will be worn during a previous
service not necessarily the preceding
one maybe a few before so you have to
choose during which service will I warn
patient or the customer number three and
then once maybe it's one right then I
have to choose the parameter which is
this waiting time before I trigger the
warning okay so let's so the algorithm
okay stochastic gradient descent with
perturbation analysis you trace the
effect of modifying those X's a little
bit if I increase drag on this
particular realization what will be the
impact on the waiting times and on the
delays you can do it in any one shot so
you have a very easy calculation of the
public agent and then you do your
stochastic gradient I think we are at
five very generous with me so the goal
of the optimized appointments we use a
data driven approach so a fig a data set
with infinitesimal perturbation ology so
prostatic appointments we we sought to
do it it's convex it's nice everything
works well and practice it really works
the dynamic appointments adaptive
viability it limits the cascades of
delays that's the first-order effect
unfortunately you do not have convey
global convexity for this problem that's
not what you know so when you run your
algorithm you have to try the false
rafting points and then find the best
one so that ocean unfortunately but is
quite tractable on reasonable size
problems so we are looking at situations
where you have maybe up to ten surgeries
for operating thank you
[Applause]
yes so you can do it for multiple
operating goals but the problem is that
if you dispatch patients based on the ad
times in the default operating rooms you
used its convexity so so you can so what
you would do you have the schedule that
has been provided by the scheduler right
of the hospital and you know which how
many cases you have and then you try to
assign them to the default of operating
us and you you simulate what would
happen by something from previous
durations and you use your gradient
algorithm that will tell you okay when
to this went to war and went to dispatch
but again you lose convexity so it
becomes complex the policy that this
requires real-time signaling of events
so the nerves in the operating room has
to tell which she has to click on the
tablett saying this surgery is almost
done and this goes down to the system
that will then warn everybody right that
turns out to be a big deal the nurses do
not want to have to do extra work right
so it will take us a while before we can
turn around some hospitals to those new
techniques it's surprising right the UPS
driver will scan every package that he
drops he will track in real time what he
does but inside the operating room they
do after the fact they do what they call
charting
so they report on what they did during
the day but there's a big lock and when
they do it and sometimes it's first time
maybe in fifth or not it's not like this
but in in the u.s. in most hospitals it
is like that
tiny windows and lumber tells you yeah
so you tell them so for the plumber or
for the the patients J your surgery will
be in the afternoon
be ready it's tough to be a ready around
noon right but we will tell you when you
should come and then they cannot they
can leave the house maybe up to 30
instead of you yeah you combine those
ideas the delay is compared to when they
are supposed to come right so we tell
them to come at noon and then it's the
delay afternoon that counts yes because
everything is bounded uniformly bounded
yeah yeah no back dominated convergence
works thank you very much